for Madeline McCann's parents they're
still hope she's alive
but prosecutor hands Christian voters
says he's leading a murder investigation
Madeline's parents still believe she
could be alive why do you call it a
murder investigation
sir so many facts that she's dead so
there's there's no opportunity that
she's still living the case against the
new suspect Christian be is
circumstantial he's a convicted child
sex abuse er he lived along Portugal's
Algarve coast for 12 years his last home
was in pride deluge where Madeleine
vanished his phone was used outside the
Macan apartment the night she
disappeared
the amnesty lie from Ella McCain begin
about of an austere seat orders we don't
have Madeleine McCann's body but we
expect that she's dead we have some
evidence that the suspect has done the
deed but we need more information from
people places he has lived so we can
target this place especially and search
there for Medellin forensic examination
of the suspects campervan is thought to
have found no trace of Madeline's DNA
and none in his Jaguar car which was
also seized we hope that some British
tourists can help us to find the murder
of Melanie mackenz like their Scotland
Yard colleagues German prosecutors have
received hundreds of calls after last
week's appeals for help visually divider
we think the suspect has committed more
crimes possibly against British people
and Irish and Americans we think there
are more victims of sexual crimes
the suspect is in jail in Germany he too
is awaiting developments in the case
detectives haven't yet questioned him
about Madeleine